.
* Geheimnisvolle Musik *
Ich brauche mehr Licht.
More light, please.
Ein verdeckter Ermittler.
- Einen unserer Männer
der serbischen Mafia ausliefern?
Bist du irre?
Und was hat das Ganze
mit mir zu tun?
Willst du mich verarschen?
Wie gut kennst du Porno-Slang?
- Ich bin im Porno zu Hause.
Und?
Wir brauchen dich.
- Kannst du nicht aufhören?
Ich bin so kurz davor.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Mysteriöse Klänge *
(TV-Stimmen)
Aus sportlicher Sicht
brachte dieser Sonntag
eine Überraschung. Die Schwyzerin ...
Der Demokrat Barack Obama holt auf.
Bei den Präsidentschaftsvorwahlen ...
... scheint in der ganzen Schweiz die
Sonne, mit wenigen Schleierwolken.
53 Eintritte.
Zwölf Leute sind noch da.
Zwölfeinhalb.
Und dort oben sind auch noch einige.
Ich gehe hoch.
Sag Rolf,
dass in 30 Min. Feierabend ist.
Wir schliessen in 30 Min.
Wir schliessen gleich.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
* Düstere Klänge *
Hey, auf den Boden!
Runter
oder ich schiesse dir in den Kopf!
Schnell! Runter!
Runterkommen! Auf den Boden!
(Lukas Gloor) Sie wussten
sehr präzise, wohin sie gingen.
Sie wussten,
wo die wertvollsten Bilder waren.
Sie machten keine Umwege.
Nicht zu den alten Holländern
und sich dann neu orientiert.
Sondern rein
und die ersten vier Bilder ...
Hey! Auf den Boden!
... abgeschnitten.
* Husten *
Ruhe!
Brže!
* Husten, Alarm *
Ruhe!
Sie konnte 30-40 Sek.
nach Start des Überfalls
via 117 die Polizei informieren.
Sie schilderte uns, was abging.
Wir werden überfallen.
Jemand bedroht uns mit einer Pistole.
Sammlung Bührle, Zollikerstrasse.
* Alarm *
Sie laden jetzt die Bilder
in den Kofferraum.
Nein,
wie sie mit den Bildern umgehen.
Den mit der Waffe sehe ich nicht.
Ajde, ajde!
- Doch, da ist er.
Er setzt sich ans Steuer.
Die anderen steigen jetzt auch ein.
Sie fahren los.
Ich kann es nicht lesen.
Ein weisser Wagen.
Oh Gott,
der Kofferraum ist noch offen.
Ich arbeitete schon viele Jahre
mit meiner Betriebsleiterin
zusammen.
Ich wusste, dass sie cool ist.
Ja, sie war sachlich. No-nonsense.
Sie wusste einfach:
Jetzt muss man schauen,
dass man das möglichst rasch
in den Griff kriegt. Das gelang.
Der Alarm schrillte noch,
als die Polizei vorfuhr.
So schnell war die Polizei da.
Aber noch schneller
waren die Räuber weg.
Sie fuhren weg und hatten
den Kofferraum noch offen.
Sie konnten ihn nicht schliessen,
weil die Bilder zu gross waren.
(Radio) Der FC Basel
gewinnt gegen Xamax 3:0
und sichert sich damit
die Tabellenspitze.
Die gewinnen nur, weil sie Geld von
dieser Pharma-Milliardärin haben.
Das Wichtigste beim Fussball
ist das Team.
Die teuer eingekauften Stars.
Sich immer wieder freispielen,
die anderen nicht hängen lassen ...
Schön wär's.
Es ist wie bei der Polizei:
Eine Chance hast du nur als Team.
Aber wenn du den Penalty
verschiesst, bist du ganz allein.
(Funk) An alle Einheiten:
Raubüberfall an der Zollikerstrasse.
Die Täterschaft ist
mit einem weissen PW auf der Flucht.
Kennzeichen unbekannt,
die Täter könnten bewaffnet sein.
* Dramatische Musik *
Wir wussten, dass sicher drei Männer
die Tat begangen hatten.
Einer davon war bewaffnet.
Wir wussten, dass ein
slawischer Dialekt gesprochen wurde.
Und man wusste, dass vier Bilder
gestohlen worden waren.
Der Überfall dauerte genau 95 Sek.
Der Tatort selbst war ernüchternd.
Man hatte sehr wenige Spuren.
Man hatte die Auskunft der Personen,
die überfallen worden waren.
Man hatte kein Video.
Man hatte die Waffe,
die bewusst zurückgelassen wurde.
Man hatte einen Hinweis
auf das Fahrzeug, das wegfuhr.
Sonst hatte man eigentlich nichts.
(Schlagzeilen)
Bewaffnete Unbekannte überfielen
die Bührle-Sammlung in Zürich.
Einer der grössten Kunstdiebstähle
aller Zeiten.
Hier ist das Erste Deutsche Fernsehen
mit der "Tagesschau".
In der Schweiz wurde
ein spektakulärer Kunstraub verübt.
In Switzerland,
the biggest art heist ever ...
... a spectacular heist, maybe the
biggest in modern European history.
Ich stieg sofort ins Auto.
Ich kam dann vor das Haus.
Meine Betriebsleiterin
stand drinnen.
Ich sah durchs Fenster, wie sie
auf dem Treppenabsatz stand.
Sie durfte nicht raus,
ich durfte nicht rein,
also telefonierten wir.
Dann fing sie an, aufzuzählen,
was fehlte.
Und diese Aufzählung hat und hat
kein Ende mehr genommen.
(Frau) "Der Knabe mit
der roten Weste" von Paul Cézanne.
"Mohnfeld bei Vétheuil"
von Claude Monet.
"Ludovic Lepic und seine Töchter"
von Edgar Degas.
"Blühende Kastanienzweige"
von Vincent van Gogh.
Für einen Museumsdirektor ist das
eine der schlimmeren Erfahrungen,
die man machen kann.
Wenn man mit so einer Sammlung lebt,
ist man mit den Bildern vertraut,
fast wie mit einer Familie.
Und jetzt wurden vier Familien-
mitglieder einfach gekidnappt.
* Düstere Musik *
Willst du jedes Auto kontrollieren?
Das macht null Sinn.
Die sind längst über alle Berge.
Du findest nichts mehr.
Woher weisst du das?
Denk an die Rammbocküberfälle
auf Juweliere.
Die fuhren mit dem Auto
voll in die Scheibe rein.
Das nächste Auto stand schon bereit.
Die sind brutal gut organisiert.
Bilder sind keine Juwelen, Mario.
- Es ist das gleiche Vorgehen.
Die sind viel schwerer
zu transportieren.
Und schwieriger zu verkaufen.
Der Polizei ist bekannt,
dass bei solchen Überfällen
die ersten Fluchtfahrzeuge
nicht wahnsinnig weit fahren.
Das war der Grund, weshalb wir
am Montag in der näheren Umgebung -
nein, in der weiteren Umgebung -
mehrere Tausend Fahrzeuge
überprüften.
Wir notierten und kontrollierten
jedes Fahrzeug.
Limmat 89 hat verstanden.
Fahrzeug ist negativ.
Was hast du erwartet?
Und? Erzähl!
Habt ihr die Juwelendiebe erwischt?
Was meinst du,
weshalb ich wieder auf Streife bin?
* Düstere Musik *
Guten Morgen.
Das ist die Wand,
an der die Bilder hingen.
Das ist das Resultat
der immer gleichen Problematik:
Man muss entscheiden
zwischen Feuerschutz
und Diebstahlschutz.
Wenn ich sie
gegen Diebstahl schützen will,
kann ich sie gar nicht
fest genug anschrauben.
Aber wenn sie an allen vier Ecken
in die Wand gedübelt sind,
kann ich bei einem Brand
nur noch zuschauen,
wie sie in Flammen aufgehen.
Die Sammlung Bührle
gehört zu den wertvollsten
Privatsammlungen der Schweiz.
Meisterwerke von van Gogh
über Picasso bis zu Gauguin
hängen an den Wänden.
Alles Gemälde von unschätzbarem Wert.
Papi!
Emma, meine Prinzessin,
schläfst du noch nicht?
Du musst mir noch
eine Gutenachtgeschichte vorlesen.
Emma konnte nicht schlafen
und wartete auf dich.
Ist das wahr?
- Mhm.
"Plavi Slon" -
"Der blaue Elefant im Orchester".
So: # Ta-da, ta-ra-ta-ta-ta-da-da!
# Ta-da-da! Genau.
Das finde ich nicht so gut.
Ich mag den Elefanten.
Ich mag ihn auch.
Ich glaube, er findet eine Lösung,
um das Konzert zu retten.
Und wie?
Und wie? Das erzähle ich dir morgen.
Jetzt ist Schlafenszeit.
- Aber du musst hierbleiben.
Ein bisschen.
- Ja.
Okay. Nehmen wir die noch ab. So.
(TV-Sprecher) 3 Min.
brauchten die Räuber für ihre Tat,
dann verliessen sie das Museum.
Es ist nicht bekannt, ob eine
Videoüberwachung die Täter filmte.
Die Polizei gibt sich zugeknöpft.
(Mann)
Das ist eine taktische Überlegung,
die die Polizei
und das Museum zusammen trafen.
Wir möchten dazu
keine Aussagen machen.
So flüchteten die Täter im
grössten Kunstraubfall der Schweiz.
Wisst ihr schon mehr?
Die sind längst über alle Berge.
(TV-Sprecher)
Ob die Polizei eine heisse Spur hat,
will sie nicht sagen.
- Wie letztes Mal auch.
Sie gehe Hinweisen
aus der Bevölkerung nach.
* Düstere Musik *
Wir hatten natürlich Schätzungen
von den grossen Auktionshäusern.
Und es war ganz klar:
Cézanne, das bekannteste Bild
der vier, die abhandenkamen,
musste bereits zu diesem Zeitpunkt
in einer Kategorie
mit einem dreistelligen
Millionenbetrag platziert werden.
100 Mio.
* Düstere Musik *
Wir wussten aber, dass van Gogh
viel bekannter ist als Cézanne.
Und von van Gogh
kam das grosse Stillleben abhanden.
Also hatten wir da
nicht viel Freiheit.
Wenn Cézanne 100 Mio. ist,
muss van Gogh fast 100 Mio. sein.
Wir haben uns
für 90 Mio. entschieden.
* Düstere Musik *
Und für Monet 25 Mio.
Und für Degas 10 Mio.
100'000 Fr. Belohnung
hat das Museum ausgesetzt.
Man hofft, Mitwisser
finanziell damit zu ködern.
Der Betrag von 100'000 Fr.
ist in der Schweiz einmalig hoch.
Deshalb sind wir nicht überrascht,
dass wir viele Hinweise erhielten.
Mehrere Dutzend
aus dem In- und Ausland.
(Erwin Brühlmann) Die Konsequenz
des Finderlohns war natürlich,
dass sich
relativ viele Leute meldeten.
Von Wahrsagern,
von Mexiko bis Dubai ...
Die ganze Bandbreite war dabei.
Orte, wo diese Bilder seien.
Wir bekamen auch Anrufe von Leuten,
die sagten,
der Betrag sei zu niedrig.
Sie würden erst sagen,
wo die Bilder seien,
wenn sie einen viel höheren Betrag
bekommen würden.
Solche waren auch dabei.
Am Nachmittag erhielt
die Stadtpolizei Zürich einen Anruf,
dass man auf dem Parkplatz der
Psychiatrischen Klinik Burghölzli,
ganz in der Nähe
der Sammlung E.G. Bührle,
ein weisses Auto gefunden habe.
Das Fahrzeug stand eine Woche lang
auf diesem Parkplatz,
aber niemand
bemerkte die Bilder darin.
Ich dachte zuerst,
das könne gar nicht sein,
das hätten wir doch gesehen.
Dieser Moment ging mir sehr nahe,
im negativen Sinn,
als ich die Liste checkte.
Wir hatten über 10'000 Autos
überprüft.
Ich musste feststellen, dass
dieses Fahrzeug auf der Liste war.
Wir hatten eine Meldung,
dass aus dem Auto Drähte hingen.
Wir schauten vor Ort
mit einem Bombenentschärfungsteam,
weil man die Drähte
nicht einordnen konnte.
Wir stellten auch fest,
dass das Auto unverschlossen war.
Das machte auch keinen Sinn.
Es konnte nicht sein, dass diese
Bilder dort waren, unverschlossen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich gebe offen zu, ich dachte,
das sei ein Studentenscherz.
Dann wurde ich
an das Auto herangeführt.
Ein riesiger Apparat rundum,
gesichert und alles.
Man liess mich kaum
in die Nähe des Autos,
wegen der Spurensicherung.
Ich sagte, ich müsse wenigstens
mal reinschauen dürfen.
Ein Blick reichte, um zu merken,
dass es keine Reproduktion war.
Es war das Objekt selbst.
(Mann) Der internationalen Presse
präsentiert der Museumsdirektor
die zurückgekehrten Monet
und van Gogh.
Das übertraf
die kühnsten Erwartungen.
Das konnten
und durften wir nicht erwarten.
Das war ein Geschenk des Himmels.
Aber auch im Wissen darum,
dass die zwei anderen noch fehlten.
* Düstere Musik *
(Erwin Brühlmann) Im Auto fand man -
nebst den Bildern -
einen Zigarettenstummel,
einen Kapuzenpulli,
zwei Sturmhauben, also Wollmützen
mit Seh- und Mundschlitz
und einen schwarzen Handschuh.
Das hat Spuren gegeben:
Man konnte die DNA sichern.
Weil die DNA-Spur
schon in Zusammenhang
mit einem anderen Delikt stand,
konnte man sagen,
dass der Täter
zu einer Gruppierung gehört,
die im Bereich von Bijouterie-
Überfällen international tätig war.
Man konnte das
einer Person aus Serbien zuordnen.
Diese Person gehörte in das Umfeld
von organisierten Banden,
den sog. Pink Panthers.
Diese Person trat auch schon
in einem sog. Rammbockeinbruch auf,
bei dem die Täterschaft
mittels Brachialgewalt
eine Scheibe aufbricht
und Geschäfte ausräumt.
* Dramatische Musik *
Für uns in Serbien war diese
Nachricht deshalb von Interesse,
weil wir zu diesem Zeitpunkt
schon sehr viel
über die Pink-Panther-Bande
berichtet hatten.
Sie waren also bereits bekannt
als Verbrecherbande,
die in ganz Europa
Raubüberfälle beging.
Bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatten sie
noch nie Museen ausgeraubt,
sondern Juweliergeschäfte überfallen
und Juwelen gestohlen.
Es war das erste Mal,
dass wir die Vermutung hatten,
dass vielleicht
die Pink-Panther-Bande
hinter diesem Kunstraub
stecken könnte.
(Peter Bächer) Die Delikte
aus diesem Phänomenbereich
haben
einen ganz speziellen Charakter:
Man hat sich sehr seriös und
minutiös auf die Tat vorbereitet.
Man hat Fluchtwege abgeklärt.
Man hat Fahrzeuge gestohlen
und bereitgestellt
für den Tag X.
Man hat in der Schweiz
auch ein Beziehungsnetz gepflegt,
bei dem vom Auskundschafter
bis zum Tatausführenden
verschiedene Rollen
eingenommen wurden.
Das passte sehr gut
zu diesem Bilderraub.
Wir stellten uns die Frage,
weshalb die Täterschaft,
wie es wirkte, ganz bewusst,
die Waffe zurückliess.
Zum Zeitpunkt des Überfalls gingen
alle anwesenden Personen davon aus,
dass es eine richtige Waffe sei.
Man stellte dann aber schnell fest,
dass es sich um
eine Plastikspielzeugwaffe handelte.
Es war eine sehr gute Imitation.
Es war ein spanisches Produkt,
konnten wir
durch die Ermittlungen feststellen.
Auf der Seite stand "Magnum".
Wir konnten nur mutmassen, welche
Überlegung da dahintersteckte -
v.a. die strafrechtliche Relevanz.
Das ist ein Aspekt, der eine Rolle
gespielt haben dürfte.
* Mysteriöse Klänge *
Im Rahmen
der fast dreimonatigen Taskforce
gab es viele Hinweise,
die in genau diese Richtung gingen,
wo die Bilder
allerorts sein sollten.
Das hat von unserer Seite
viele Aktionen wie Haus-
durchsuchungen nach sich gezogen.
Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt,
als wir die Taskforce führten,
konnten wir die Spuren
aber nicht erhärten.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Beat Rhyner)
Ich wurde zum ersten Mal involviert,
als wir von
einer ausländischen Polizeibehörde
eine Mitteilung erhielten,
dass sich bei ihnen
jemand gemeldet habe,
der sage, er hätte Informationen
über den Standort
der beiden noch fehlenden Bilder.
Es ist immer schwierig,
einzuschätzen,
wie weit man Privatpersonen
trauen kann.
Aber diese Person war im Ausland
bei dieser Polizeibehörde bekannt.
Man wusste,
was er bisher schon gemacht hatte,
dass er kein Schwerkrimineller ist,
aber sich wirklich
in diesem Umfeld bewegt.
Er konnte glaubhaft schildern,
dass diese Tätergruppierung
die Bilder verkaufen will.
Und dass er überzeugt ist, dass er
als Käufer auftreten könnte
und so dafür sorgen könnte,
dass die Bilder zurückkommen.
Für uns war von Anfang an klar,
dass wir auf das erste Bild,
auf Degas, fokussieren wollten.
Bei dem war der Kaufpreis
auch deutlich tiefer.
Bei Cézanne
sprechen wir von mehreren Millionen.
Bei Degas war die Rede
von mehreren Hunderttausend Euro.
Man hat uns
um eine halbe Million Euro gebeten.
Wir wussten, dass diese Raubüber-
fälle eigentlich Artnapping sind.
Es ist ja immer klar:
Auf dem offenen Markt
lässt sich ein gestohlenes Kunstwerk
nicht verkaufen.
Der böse Oligarch,
der irgendwo sitzt,
der sich still und leise über
so ein Bild freut, gibt es nicht.
Das weiss man auch.
Bilder werden gestohlen,
um Lösegeld flüssigzumachen.
Ab dem Moment, an dem unser
Mittelsmann nach Serbien reiste,
hatten wir keine direkte Kontrolle.
Wir mussten ihm vertrauen
und darauf setzen,
dass der Plan so funktionierte,
wie er sich das vorgestellt hatte.
Es war nicht auszuschliessen,
dass ihm die Gegenseite
einfach das Geld abnimmt
und das Bild behält.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wir identifizierten
den Verhandlungspartner
unseres Mittelsmanns namentlich.
Wir wussten, wer das war.
Bobe N. war einer der Fusssoldaten
in dieser serbischen Gruppierung.
Er hat direkten Zugang zum Chef,
aber er ist nicht der,
der entscheidet.
Er ist der loyale,
zuverlässige Handlanger des Chefs.
Der Mittelsmann
war dafür verantwortlich,
dass das Bild in die Schweiz kommt,
in den Grossraum Zürich.
Wir vereinbarten einen Treffpunkt.
Das war ein ganz spannender Moment.
Das verpackte Bild.
Ist es das wirklich?
Alle standen darum herum.
Man nahm die Abdeckung weg.
Und siehe da, es war das Bild.
Das war eine grosse Freude
und Erleichterung.
Auf diesem Weg
bekamen wir ein zwar lädiertes,
aber immer noch vollständiges Bild
zurück.
Der Mittelsmann hätte den Cézanne
möglicherweise auf dem gleichen Weg
beschaffen können.
Das wollten wir aber nicht.
Einerseits ist das Risiko,
dass beim zweiten Bild
das Geld weg ist,
das Bild aber nicht zurückkommt,
deutlich grösser.
Und wir hatten
einen guten Ansatzpunkt,
über Bobe N. weiterzukommen.
* Klopfen *
Herein.
Paul.
- Markus.
Und, was hast du?
- Der Fall Bührle.
Mhm.
Ihr habt für dieses Bild
Lösegeld bezahlt?
Ja, wir hatten keine andere Wahl.
Wer weiss davon?
Wir, und die Leute von der Stiftung.
Und Cézanne?
Bei Cézanne
funktionierte es nicht mehr.
Da war zu viel Geld im Spiel.
Und wer ist der Hehler?
- Bobe.
Wir kennen ihn.
Wir kennen sein Umfeld.
Aber wir kamen nie ganz an ihn ran.
Er tummelt sich zwischen Belgrad
und Westeuropa.
Aber das kannst du vergessen,
an den kommst du nicht ran.
Und die Serben?
- Zu korrupt.
Besorge mir Kontakt
zum Oberstaatsanwalt in Belgrad.
Weshalb das jetzt?
Ich glaube,
so könnte es funktionieren.
Was?
Wir setzen einen verdeckten Ermittler
auf den Hehler an.
Einen unserer Männer
der serbischen Mafia ausliefern?
Bist du irre? Viel zu riskant.
- Hast du eine bessere Idee?
Ich will Cézanne zurück
und die Täter hinter Gittern.
Bobe ist die einzige Chance.
Der Staatsanwalt musste überlegen,
wie er die Beweisführung
machen konnte.
Er kam schnell zur Einsicht,
dass das nur mit einem Einsatz
von verdeckten Ermittlern geht.
Wir beschritten diesen Weg,
weil sich die Staatsanwaltschaft -
und das ist sehr speziell,
das muss man betonen -
nicht die Wiederbeschaffung
der Bilder
als oberstes Ziel gesetzt hat,
sondern uns den Auftrag gegeben hat,
nicht nur die Bilder zu finden,
sondern die Gegenseite
zu identifizieren,
damit die Verantwortlichen zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden können.
Ajde, Emma! Idemo!
Hopp!
* Er wiehert. *
Halt dich fest!
Achtung!
Papi, wann darf ich endlich
auf einem richtigen Pferd reiten?
Bin ich dir nicht echt genug,
du kleine ...
Hier, meine beiden Pferdchen. Hopp!
Da, für dich. Mmh, lecker!
* Summton *
Ja?
Zu Hause.
Wie, jetzt?
Okay, ich komme.
Was ist?
- Ich muss nochmals los.
Was, jetzt?
Ja, das beste Pferd muss los.
* Wiehern *
* Emma jauchzt, Mario wiehert. *
(Beat Rhyner) Als wir uns
für die verdeckte Ermittlung
entschieden hatten, kam
eine lange Phase der Vorbereitung.
Das macht man nicht
von einem Tag auf den nächsten.
Achtung, fertig, los.
Dazu gehörte auch, dass wir Bobe N.
systematisch überwachten.
Wir schauten,
was er den ganzen Tag macht,
wie er sich verhält,
mit wem er zusammen ist.
Wir spionierten
seinen ganzen Lebensstil etwas aus.
Man muss sich zuerst überlegen,
was für eine Story man haben will,
welche Identität der
verdeckte Ermittler haben sollte:
Was für ein Bild
gibt der verdeckte Ermittler?
Was für eine Person ist er,
damit er das Interesse
der Täterschaft weckt,
der Verdächtigen, die man angeht?
Dann muss man mit der Polizei
Rücksprache nehmen
und schauen,
ob die Geschichte gut ist,
und ob sie
einen verdeckten Ermittler haben,
die sie so durchbringen kann.
Hast du seine Akte gelesen?
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das unser Mann ist.
Der lässt sich kaum führen.
Und hast du sie gelesen?
Beim letzten Einsatz
mussten wir ihn rausholen,
weil er zu weit gegangen ist.
- Ich will ihn.
Meine Entscheidung.
- Aber meine Verantwortung.
Die Zeit rennt uns davon.
Auch wenn ihm die Erfahrung fehlt,
hat er alles, was es braucht.
Ich habe ihn schon lange nicht mehr
gesehen und keinen Bock ...
Guten Tag.
-Mario. Nimm Platz.
Also ... Es geht um den Bührle-Raub.
Die zwei Bilder,
in einem weissen Opel.
Das sagt mir was.
- Das wichtigste Bild fehlt.
Habe ich gehört.
Staatsanwalt Ballmer.
- Und?
Der Fall Bührle führt zu denselben
Leuten wie die Bijouterie-Überfälle.
Wir haben eine Spur zu denen,
die das Bild haben.
Das ist Bobe. Serbe.
Notorisch kriminell.
In ganz Europa aktiv.
Verbindungen zu den Pink Panthers.
Er wohnt in Holland
und wurde gestern verhaftet -
wegen häuslicher Gewalt.
D.h., wir wissen sehr genau,
wo er in den nächsten Wochen
seine Geschäfte verrichtet.
Gut. Und was hat das Ganze
mit mir zu tun?
Sie sprechen doch Serbisch.
- Bosnisch, ja.
Und Sie haben Erfahrungen
als verdeckter Ermittler.
Ich bin jetzt im Streifendienst.
Sie kamen zur Polizei,
um Karriere zu machen.
Ja, das sagt man in jungen Jahren.
- Fokussiert ...
... kontrolliert, ehrgeizig.
- Familienmensch.
Wollen Sie die Leute fassen,
die mutmasslich verantwortlich sind
für den Tod Ihres Kollegen ...
... Sascha Gerber?
Er ist nicht mein Kollege.
Er war mein bester Freund.
* Düstere Musik *
Der verdeckte Ermittler wusste,
dass er in einem Milieu
eingesetzt werden wird,
in dem die organisierte Kriminalität
tätig ist.
Er wusste, dass die Täterschaft
durchaus sehr gewaltbereit ist.
Und er wusste,
wenn er auffliegen würde,
könnte das sehr böse Folgen für ihn
haben.
Hallo.
- Hey.
Oh, wow!
Haben wir etwas zu feiern?
- Ja ...
Emma schläft schon?
- Ja, ja.
Schau hier.
- Was ist das für ein feiner Wein?
Hier auch ein bisschen.
Danke.
- Bitte. Wie war dein Tag?
Schlimmer kann es nicht werden.
Dafür gibt es heute
Pasta alla Mario.
Handmade.
Oh!
Okay.
Auf uns.
- Auf uns.
Mario, was ist los?
Ich ... Ich muss nochmals
für ein paar Wochen weg.
Vielleicht auch länger.
- Länger?
Die haben eine Spur
zur serbischen Mafia gefunden.
Ich soll sie aufnehmen,
als Verdeckter.
Weshalb du?
Kann das nicht jemand anders machen?
Du bist doch auf Streife.
- Nicht mehr.
Was?
Nein. Das ...
Das haben wir doch abgemacht.
Weisst du nicht mehr?
- Ich weiss, Rebekka.
Es ist ...
- "Nie mehr" hast du gesagt.
Sch, Emma.
Mario.
Du hast mir das versprochen.
Wir wollen ein normales Leben,
nach allem, was passiert ist.
Was ist mit Emma?
Wie stellst du dir das vor?
Ich weiss, Rebekka.
Ich konnte einfach nicht Nein sagen.
Nicht, nach allem, was passiert ist.
Ich mache es für ihn. Bitte.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Du bringst Sascha nicht zurück, indem
du dein Leben aufs Spiel setzt -
und das deiner Familie.
(Emma) Mami?
Emma, Schätzchen, alles ist gut.
Alles ist gut.
Zu den Eigenschaften,
die ein guter verdeckter Ermittler
mitbringen muss,
gehört insbesondere die Fähigkeit,
in eine andere Rolle zu schlüpfen
und das glaubhaft zu verkörpern.
Sie müssen gute Schauspieler sein.
Und sie müssen
extrem gut lügen können -
glaubwürdig lügen,
über eine längere Zeit.
Eine Geschichte erzählen,
die so überzeugend ist,
dass das auch
die kriminelle Gegenseite glaubt
und Vertrauen aufbaut.
Dafür müssen sie sich
andere Persönlichkeiten zulegen,
ein Alter Ego,
das sie glaubhaft verkörpern können,
eine Rolle, in der sie
längere Zeit leben können.
Und sie müssen zwischen der normalen
und der fiktiven Persönlichkeit
switchen können.
Dragan.
* Er räuspert sich. *
Was gibt's?
Wie kommst du an die Frauen ran?
(Hochdeutsch mit Akzent)
Ich habe eine gute Nase,
wenn es um Girls geht,
die bei geilen Typen punkten.
Und wie kommst du
zu deiner guten Nase?
Jahrelange Erfahrung
und einige Selbstversuche,
die mir nicht geschadet haben.
Und die Frauen
lassen sich alles gefallen?
Natürlich. Ich glaube,
ich hätte da was für dich.
Müsstest du mal ausprobieren.
- Was, zum Beispiel?
Einen Dreier, vielleicht.
Mit golden Shower.
Mmh!
Schwierig wird es erst,
wenn sie anfangen, mitzureden.
Du weisst schon,
der ganze Feministenscheiss.
Ich wusste nicht,
dass das Wort "Feministinnen"
zum Vokabular eines Porno-Produzenten
gehört.
Und vergiss den Ehering nicht.
Bei einem solchen Einsatz
erschafft man
eine sehr spezifische Geschichte.
Das Porno-Business wählte man,
weil man dachte,
das könnte für Bobe N.
spannend sein.
Aufregend.
Frauen, Sex, Drogen, Geld ...
Das ist noch spannend
für eine Person wie Bobe N.,
die aus dem serbischen
kriminellen Milieu kommt.
Wie gut kennst du Porno-Slang?
- Ich bin im Porno zu Hause.
Wie heisst die Frau,
die auf dem Filmset
die Erektion der Darsteller
aufrechterhält?
Fluff-Girl.
Wie nennt man die Nahaufnahme
des Schwanzes?
Machst du Witze?
Das weiss doch jeder.
Was sagt deine Frau, Rebekka,
zum Ganzen?
Nichts.
Wie viel hast du ihr erzählt?
Nur das Nötigste.
Wie reagierst du, wenn du auffliegst?
Ich fliege nicht auf.
* Dramatische Musik *
Zusätzlich
müssen verdeckte Ermittler
ausserordentlich kaltblütig sein.
Sie müssen schlagfertig sein.
Bei überraschenden Problemen
müssen sie ruhig reagieren,
sich herausreden
und nicht auffliegen.
Sei etwas unterwürfig.
Lass ihn die ersten Schritte machen.
Du bist der Handlanger.
Überlasse ihm die Chefrolle.
Also, Mario.
Ausweise.
Kreditkarte.
Handy.
Das ist eure Website.
Geschäftsadresse.
Das ist dein Chef, Dieter.
Meine Geschichte ...
Hält sie stand?
Alles abgesichert.
(Beat Rhyner) Es ist mit einem
anderen Namen und Pass nicht getan.
Man konstruiert
eine ganze Persönlichkeit.
Wenn er sagt,
er sei in einer Stadt aufgewachsen,
muss er diese Stadt kennen.
Oder es muss so unüberprüfbar sein,
dass man nicht checkt,
dass die Geschichte nicht stimmt.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Der verdeckte Ermittler
musste einen etwas unbeholfenen,
aber sympathischen Kleinkriminellen
spielen,
der denselben ethnisch-kulturellen
Background hat wie Bobe N.,
der auch Serbisch spricht,
sodass man sich nahesteht.
Ein junger, eher unerfahrener,
der zu Bobe N. hochschaut,
der der erfahrene, grosse,
richtige serbische Kriminelle ist.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Man musste es so gestalten,
dass unser verdeckter Ermittler
nicht zu offensichtlich
den Kontakt zu Bobe N. sucht.
Also nicht
in die gleiche Zelle einsperren.
Das wäre zu plump gewesen.
Sondern, dass unser VE auftaucht
und Bobe N. auf ihn aufmerksam wird
und ihn unter die Fittiche nimmt.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Du bist kein Serbe.
Nein, Bosnier.
Evo, cure.
Woher weisst du das?
Ich weiss alles hier.
Auch, dass du aus Deutschland bist.
Und du?
International tätig.
Und was machst du,
wenn du nicht Hausfrau spielst?
Also weisst du doch nicht alles.
Import, Export.
- Autos?
Rein, raus.
- Zuhälter?
Pornos.
Du? Ein Porno-Schauspieler?
"Darsteller" heisst das.
Darsteller, okay.
- Ich bin nicht vor der Kamera.
Sondern?
- Ich suche die Wohnungen.
Die Mädchen. Marketing.
Ich schaue, dass der Stoff da ist.
Du weisst schon:
Pillen und das weisse Pulver.
Und wofür sitzt du ein?
- Parkbussen.
Und du?
- Schwarzfahren.
Bobe Nedic.
Dragan Jostranovic. Dragomir.
Du gefällst mir.
(Beat Rhyner) Für uns
war es ein grosser Durchbruch,
weil wir dadurch
einen Kontakt zu Bobe N. hatten.
Er war der, der beim ersten Bild
mit dem Mittelsmann verhandelt hat.
Der Kontakt fand statt.
Man war sich sympathisch.
Eine gute Grundlage,
um ein Vertrauensverhältnis
aufzubauen.
Die verdeckte Ermittlung
ist eine Massnahme,
die sehr aufwendig
und risikobehaftet ist.
Sie kann -
und das gibt das Gesetz so vor -
nur dann angewendet werden,
wenn es darum geht, in
ein kriminelles Umfeld einzudringen,
und sich das als letzte
mögliche Massnahme erweist.
* Düstere Musik *
(Emma) Der Elefant liebt die Trommel,
aber alle finden,
er würde viel besser Posaune spielen,
mit seinem Rüssel. So:
# Tä-rä, tä-rä-tä-tä-tä-tä-tä!
Dann hat er aus Versehen
alle kaputt gemacht,
weil er so stampft.
Und jetzt sind alle wütend auf ihn.
Und er hat noch keine Lösung
gefunden, um das Konzert zu retten.
Keine Lösung gefunden?
Aber er findet sicher eine.
Der verdeckte Ermittler
war ein paar Tage im Gefängnis.
Wenn er aus dem Gefängnis rauskommt,
hofft er, dass der Kontakt
mit der Zielperson bestehen bleibt,
wenn diese aus dem Gefängnis kommt.
Auch da hatten wir Glück.
Bobe N. war so interessiert,
dass er sich nach seiner Entlassung
beim verdeckten Ermittler meldete.
Serbien
oder das ehemalige Jugoslawien
hat eine lange Tradition,
wenn es um organisierte
Raubüberfälle in Europa geht.
Das ist deshalb wichtig,
weil all diese Verbrecher
von der serbischen Geheimpolizei
die Erlaubnis erhielten,
Raubüberfälle in Europa zu begehen
und mit der Beute zurückzukehren
und in Freiheit zu leben.
Dann brach der Krieg aus
und die meisten dieser Verbrecher
landeten an der Front,
wo sie einfach weitermachten.
Einer der ersten
grossen Raubüberfälle dieser Zeit
war 1993 in London.
Danach organisierten sie
Raubüberfälle in ganz Europa.
In der serbischen Öffentlichkeit
hatten sie den Ruf
als die good Guys.
Man sah sie als die Guten,
als erfolgreiche Diebe,
die bei ihren Taten
intelligent vorgingen
und keine Gewalt angewendet haben.
Sie waren schon gewalttätig
in dem Sinne,
dass sie Schaufenster von
Juweliergeschäften einschlugen usw.,
aber bei diesen Überfällen
wurde nie jemand getötet.
Und deswegen wurden sie
als die guten Diebe angesehen,
die von den reichen Westlern
stahlen.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Bobe interessierte sich dafür,
ins Porno-Business einzusteigen.
Und man sagte ihm,
er solle in Belgrad, wo er herkam,
nach möglichen Filmlocations suchen.
Er solle schauen, ob man dort
etwas Gescheites machen könne,
und dann werde man das
mit ihm anschauen.
Und dann könne er vielleicht
mit einsteigen.
Massiv, was?
Ja, etwas weich.
Suchst du noch ...
Wie sagst du dem? ... Darsteller?
Für die richtig harten Szenen.
Brauner Gürtel. Reicht,
damit dich niemand von hinten fickt,
hat mein Karatelehrer immer gesagt.
U pičku strinu.
Dein Boss ...
Was ist das für ein Typ?
Dieter. Deutscher.
Hat eine Menge Kohle gemacht.
Mit Pornos?
- Pornos, und allem, was dazugehört.
Drogen, Frauen ... Du weisst schon.
Wo macht ihr eure Filme?
- Überall in Europa.
Und wie genau verdient ihr Geld?
- Mit Websites.
Wenn du auf einen Film klickst,
kostet es - jede Minute.
Je geiler du wirst,
desto mehr lässt du liegen.
Hier. Dieter.
Dieter ist oft in St. Moritz.
Er hat Kontakt
zu guten und wichtigen Leuten,
die eine Menge Kohle gemacht haben.
Ich glaube, du solltest mal
nach St. Moritz mitkommen.
Das würde dir bestimmt gefallen.
Dann kann ich dir Dieter vorstellen,
wenn du willst.
Bald werde ich auch reich sein.
Ich habe ein grosses Ding am Laufen.
- Ach ja?
Kann ich dir vertrauen?
So gut kennen wir uns nicht.
Du könntest ein Bulle sein
und mich verpfeifen.
Verpfeifst du mich?
Willst du mich erschiessen?
Wäre nicht das erste Mal,
dass ich einen Bullen abknalle.
Sehe ich aus wie ein Bulle?
(Urs Hubmann)
Man wusste, dass man es
mit den Pink Panthers zu tun hatte.
Man weiss, dass sie gewaltbereit
und skrupellos sind.
Man konnte durchaus davon ausgehen,
dass,
wenn der VE tatsächlich auffliegt,
für ihn eine Gefahr
für Leib und Leben besteht.
Auf unsere Geschäfte.
Die Mona Lisa, was?
Die echte?
- Könnte euch interessieren.
Was will ich mit einem Bild?
- Dieter vielleicht.
Wie weisst du,
dass es 100 Mio. wert ist?
Aus der Zeitung.
- Aus der Zeitung.
Ich rede mal mit Dieter.
(Beat Rhyner) Das Vertrauens-
verhältnis zwischen Bobe N.
und dem verdeckten Ermittler
wuchs stetig.
Sie waren längere Zeit
zusammen in Belgrad unterwegs.
Bobe N. hatte das Gefühl,
einen guten Kollegen und Freund
gefunden zu haben,
einen künftigen Geschäftspartner.
Das ging so weit,
dass Bobe seinen neuen Freund
zu sich nach Hause einlud.
Er wurde der Familie vorgestellt,
er war bei Familienfesten dabei,
er lernte die Kinder kennen.
Er wurde im engeren Familienkreis
als Freund aufgenommen.
Bobe Nedeljkovski
ist ein interessanter Charakter.
Ich denke,
das hat auch die Polizei gedacht,
weshalb er auch das Ziel
ihrer verdeckten Ermittlungen wurde.
Im Gefängnis in Holland
tappte er in die Falle
und stellte den Kontakt
zu diesem verdeckten Ermittler her,
den er für ein grosses Tier
in der Porno-Industrie hielt.
St. Moritz - ein weltbekannter Ort.
Das kannte auch Bobe.
Er wusste, dort ist es teuer,
dort ist der Jetset,
die wirklich reichen Leute.
Also lud man ihn für ein paar Tage
nach St. Moritz ein,
in ein Fünfsternehotel.
Teures Essen. Teuerster Wein.
Alles nur vom Feinsten.
Man geht zusammen Skifahren,
bezahlt Privatskilehrer.
Eine teure Flasche Whiskey,
die teuerste Flasche Wein.
Man zeigt Lokale: "Essen wir hier.
Bestelle, was du willst."
Ein insgesamt
überzeugender Auftritt.
Mit der Aktion in St. Moritz
wollte man
den zweiten verdeckten Ermittler
als Porno-König vorstellen.
Man wollte ihm zeigen,
dass das ein sehr potenter,
kaufwilliger Interessent ist.
Ich entschuldige mich nochmals
für die Verspätung.
Das ist sehr ungewöhnlich
in der Schweiz.
Verspätungen
können manchmal tödlich sein.
Aber es scheint gut zu laufen,
das Porno-Business.
Ich kann nicht klagen.
Herr Brenner,
Ihre Suite ist nun bereit.
Hier noch eine kleine Aufmerksamkeit
des Hauses.
Dürfen wir Sie zum Essen erwarten?
- Natürlich.
Wie sieht es mit den Extras aus?
Unser Gast
braucht dringend eine sanfte Massage.
(Beat Rhyner) Alles inszeniert
nach einem Drehbuch.
Damit Bobe sah:
"Ah, dieser Mann hat wirklich Geld."
"Das ist nicht nur Blabla."
"Er lud mich ein
und scheute keine Kosten."
Es ist für alles gesorgt.
Belgrad
soll wunderschöne Frauen haben.
Die schönsten Frauen der Welt.
Und ihr habt Djokovic.
- Djokovic, ja.
Djokovic hat Federer gefickt.
Dafür werden wir uns rächen.
- Mal sehen.
Und Wimbledon gehört auch bald uns.
Und was habt ihr
sonst noch zu bieten?
Alles, was du brauchst.
Drogen, Kokain, Speed, Pillen ...
Was du willst.
- Du bist unser Mann.
Ich habe noch etwas für dich -
etwas aus der Schweiz.
Die Idee war,
dass Bobe so weit Vertrauen fasst,
dass er davon ausgeht,
dass er mit diesem Geschäftsmann
Kontakt halten will:
"Ich muss schauen,
dass ich auch künftig
mit ihm Geschäfte machen kann."
"Ich muss bei ihm
einsteigen können."
"Jetzt muss ich dem
irgendetwas bieten."
Damit er von sich aus
wieder auf das Thema Bilder kommt,
um aufzutrumpfen und zu zeigen,
dass er etwas zu bieten hat.
Ein Bild.
- Ein Bild?
Was soll ich mit einem Bild?
- Ein Kunstwerk.
Was soll ich mit einem Kunstwerk?
- Es ist 100 Mio. Euro wert.
Okay. Und woher kommt es?
Ein Museum. Hier in der Schweiz.
- Gestohlen?
Ja.
- Und jetzt willst du es loswerden.
Bei mir zu Hause
kommt es nicht richtig zur Geltung.
Ich bin leider kein Kunsthändler.
Ich mache Pornos.
Aber du kennst Leute,
die Interesse haben könnten.
An einem geklauten Bild?
Du meinst,
es könnte jemanden interessieren,
dem es mal gehört hat?
- Vielleicht.
Jemand, der es zurückhaben will.
- Überlege es dir!
Es ist ein Cézanne.
Jetzt wollen wir uns erst mal
ein bisschen entspannen.
Und Spass haben.
Danach haben wir genug Zeit
für Kunst.
Man kann sagen, dass St. Moritz
ein sehr grosser Erfolg war,
eigentlich der Durchbruch.
Danach ging es wirklich
konkret in die Verhandlungen.
Nach St. Moritz kam man dazu,
dass man doch eigentlich
Interesse habe,
den Deal abzuwickeln.
Es wurde ein Angebot von 2,8 Mio.
für das Bild gemacht.
Und man entschied sich,
dem nachzukommen.
Der Staatsanwalt kam mit
einer Forderung nach Geld zu uns.
Mehr als letztes Mal,
aber es ging natürlich auch
um ein zehnmal wertvolleres Bild.
Aber auch hier
war innerhalb der Stiftung
und der Stifterfamilie klar,
dass man diesen Einsatz
leisten will.
Man war bereit dazu, in der
Hoffnung, das Bild zurückzubekommen.
Es ist grundsätzlich so,
dass wir für Vorzeigegeldeinsätze
gemäss Gesetz
auf die Nationalbank zugehen können.
Die Nationalbank kann dann das Geld
zur Verfügung stellen -
unter der Haftung des Gemeinwesens,
zu dem die Staatsanwaltschaft
gehört.
In diesem konkreten Fall
hat man mit der Stiftung
die Lösung gefunden,
dass die Stiftung das Vorzeigegeld,
das für den Kauf genutzt wird,
vorschiesst.
* Keuchen *
Was machst du hier?
Warum hast du nicht gesagt,
dass du zurückkommst?
Hey.
Wie lange noch?
- Nicht mehr lange.
Wir sind so nahe dran.
Ich schwöre dir,
wenn das vorbei ist,
komme ich zurück
und wir können
ein stinknormales Leben führen.
So lange kann ich nicht warten.
Wir haben eine Familie, Mario.
Wir brauchen dich.
Sind wir dir scheissegal?
Seid ihr nicht. Rebekka ...
Emma hatte ihre erste Reitstunde.
Sie war so traurig, dass sie es dir
nicht erzählen konnte.
Ich kann ihr nicht länger vorspielen,
dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Ich will das nicht mehr.
- Ich kann jetzt nicht aufhören.
Ich bin so nahe dran.
Ich habe eine Verantwortung.
Ich will, dass die in den Knast
kommen - v.a. für Sascha.
Du hast auch
eine Verantwortung uns gegenüber.
Sascha ist tot, verdammt noch mal.
Tot.
Wenn du jetzt gehst,
brauchst du nicht zurückzukommen.
Pizda ti materina.
* Eine Tür knallt zu. *
Scheisse!
Fuck!
(Beat Rhyner) Man kann nicht
verdeckter Ermittler sein,
ohne dass das die Frau
oder Partnerin weiss.
Sie müssen einverstanden sein.
Das hat eine Bedeutung
für die Familie.
Eine Ehefrau oder ein Partner ...
... darf im privaten Umfeld,
in der Familie,
auch nicht erzählen,
was der Mann macht.
In der Regel wissen die Nachbarn,
dass er Polizist ist.
Man muss auch dort
eine Geschichte erfinden,
dass er jetzt als Zivilfahnder
bei der Polizei ist.
Aber was er genau macht,
weiss natürlich niemand.
Mario.
Kannst du die Tür schliessen?
Grossartig, Mario.
Er vertraut mir -
und das ist das Wichtigste.
Schaut, dass das Geld bereit ist,
den Rest überlasst ihr mir.
Sobald wir das Bild haben
und du sicher bist, greifen wir ein.
Aber du gehst kein unnötiges Risiko
ein, verstanden?
* Düstere Musik *
Mario?
(Beat Rhyner) Es war klar,
dass die Täterschaft den Deal
nur in Serbien durchführen würde.
Die Idee war logischerweise
ein Zug-um-Zug-Geschäft.
Man trifft sich.
Idealerweise bekommt man das Bild
zuerst und kann es prüfen.
Dann die Geldübergabe.
Das wollte die Gegenseite nicht.
Die Forderung war,
wir müssten 1,4 Mio. vorauszahlen.
Dann kommt das Bild,
und dann die zweiten 1,4 Mio.
Und es war ganz klar:
Die erste Tranche ist verloren.
Die haben genügend Zeit, das Geld
irgendwo in Ruhe zu parkieren -
sei das,
dass es physisch versteckt wird,
sei das, dass es
auf ein Bankkonto transferiert wird.
Das musste man annehmen
und davon musste man ausgehen.
Man sagte dann vonseiten
der Staatsanwalt und der Polizei:
"Okay, wir steigen auf das ein,
aber nur,
wenn wir einen Beweis haben,
dass das Bild aktuell bei euch ist."
Okay.
* Piepstöne des Zahlenschlosses *
Der Geburtstag deiner Geliebten?
Nicht ganz.
Lass mich sehen!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Beat Rhyner) Wir haben verlangt,
dass wir Fotos bekommen
mit aktuellen Tageszeitungen,
damit man sieht,
dass es ein aktuelles Foto ist.
Wir wurden
von Lukas Gloor instruiert,
was die Merkmale seien,
sodass auch die verdeckten Ermittler
sagen können:
"Ja, das ist tatsächlich das Bild."
(Peter Bächer)
Als die Geldsumme bekannt wurde,
entstand für uns
ein neues, zusätzliches Risiko.
Das Leben des verdeckten Ermittlers
zu gefährden, wäre ganz schlecht.
Wenn die Ermittlungen
in sich zusammenbrechen,
wäre es ganz schlecht.
Wenn das Geld fehlte,
wäre das ein Riesenfiasko,
das ist ganz klar.
Dort mussten wir nochmals
eine andere Ebene fahren,
noch mehr Ressourcen
in das Verfahren investieren.
Wer hat gesagt, dass Geld stinkt?
Riech mal!
Ich weiss, wie das riecht.
Morgen will Dieter das Bild haben.
- Vertrau mir!
Aber was, wenn dein Chef die Kohle
und dann ...
Du glaubst, ich lüge dich an?
(Beat Rhyner)
Wir mussten 1,4 Mio. vorauszahlen,
ohne dass wir das Bild hatten.
Das komme in 24 Std.
Das ist schon mal ein Risiko.
Theoretisch hätten wir über
den Tisch gezogen werden können.
Das Geld geht, das Bild kommt nicht.
Aber wir waren zuversichtlich,
dass das stattfindet.
Aber das
hat es nicht einfacher gemacht:
Wir geben Geld aus der Hand
und haben noch nichts.
Sieht gut aus, was?
- Ja, ja.
Dann sehen wir uns später.
Der zuständige Staatsanwalt hat
sicher nicht sehr gut geschlafen.
Er muss sich aufgrund des Bildes,
das er vor Ort hat,
überlegen und sagen,
ob es etwas Geplantes ist,
etwas Aussergewöhnliches.
Natürlich
ist das ganze Team angespannt
und wartet ab, was passiert.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Rebekka, ab Band)
Wir sind gerade nicht erreichbar.
Hinterlassen Sie doch
eine Nachricht. Merci. Tschau.
Hoi, ich bin's.
Ich weiss, du willst wahrscheinlich
gerade nichts von mir hören.
Vielleicht kannst du das
Emma abspielen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Was?
Das haben wir nicht so abgemacht.
Das wird Dieter nicht gefallen,
das sage ich dir.
Du hörst von mir.
U pičku materinu.
Verdammte Scheisse.
* Klingeln *
Warte, ich rufe zurück.
Sch.
Dragan?
- Ja, ich bin's.
Die wollen nochmals 400'000.
Wir haben genau 2 Std.
Wollen die uns verarschen?
Was machen wir jetzt?
Darauf waren wir nicht vorbereitet.
Wir mussten in Belgrad ...
Wir waren alle in Belgrad -
Staatsanwalt, Kantonspolizei,
wir von der Stadtpolizei,
die Führungsperson
der verdeckten Ermittler,
die serbische Polizei,
Einsatzleiter.
Wir mussten zusammenkommen
und entscheiden, was wir machen.
Übergeben wir nochmals 400'000
und haben das Bild immer noch nicht?
Das wären fast 2 Mio. -
und keine Spur des Bildes.
Wenn das schiefläuft ...
- Das ist zu riskant.
Zu riskant.
Es war auch klar, dass nicht Bobe
entscheidet, sondern sein Chef.
Der sagt Ja oder Nein und wie.
Da blieb immer ein Restrisiko.
Man wusste nie genau, wie der tickt
und was er wirklich will.
Und ist er auch zuverlässig
und traut uns wirklich, oder nicht?
Okay, wir machen es.
Mario, hast du das gehört?
-Ja.
Und vergiss nicht,
das Handy bei dir zu haben.
Ich melde mich wieder.
- Also gut.
(Peter Bächer)
Wichtig ist natürlich,
dass der Staatsanwalt
diesen Druck aushalten kann,
dass er Möglichkeiten hat, solchen
Druck zwischendurch abzubauen
und runterzufahren.
Aber den Druck an sich
kann ihm niemand abnehmen.
Nächstes Jahr kaufe ich mir
eine schöne Wohnung, mit Aussicht.
Und vielleicht mit einem Lift?
Und dann kommst du mich besuchen.
- Klar.
Dann wird gefeiert.
Nachdem sich der Staatsanwalt
entschieden hatte,
die zusätzlich geforderten 400'000
auch zu bezahlen,
sagte er, er tue es nur,
wenn der verdeckte Ermittler
das Bild sehe.
Schönes Versteck hast du.
Mein Sohn schläft im
wertvollsten Bett in ganz Serbien.
Du bist ein guter Vater, oder?
- Hast du daran gezweifelt?
Hier, das.
Oh, Schweiz. Qualität.
- Achtung, scharf.
Wie die Scheissbullen.
Kannst du behalten.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
So, dann ganz unten,
nur mit den Fingerspitzen.
Nur schauen.
Das Risiko,
dass man den verdeckten Ermittlern
eine gute Kopie,
also eine Reproduktion, hinhält,
war da.
Also mussten wir ihnen
Hinweise geben,
die ihnen erlaubten,
zu sehen, ob es das Bild war.
Ob es das reale Bild war.
Und ich kannte ein Detail.
Wir liessen alle unsere Bilder
einmal systematisch fotografieren.
Wir nahmen den Rückseitenschutz ab
und ich sah,
dass auf der Rückseite
einfach eine Zahl stand.
Irgendjemand hat draufgekritzelt.
Drehe es mal um!
Ich rufe Dieter an.
* Handyklingeln *
Ja, Dieter, ich bin's.
Ich habe das Bild.
Ja. Der Junge ist vor mir.
Okay, gib ihm das Geld und dann ab -
ins Auto mit dem Jungen.
Dragan, jetzt ganz vorsichtig.
Wir sind ganz nahe bei dir.
Okay.
Hier sind die 400'000.
Den Rest gibt's im Hotel,
wie vereinbart.
* Ein Kind ruft auf Serbisch. *
Wie war das nochmals
bei diesem Juwelier-Überfall?
Wurdet ihr nie erwischt?
Was meinst du?
Du hast gesagt,
du hast auf jemanden geschossen.
War ein Bulle.
Er hatte es auf mich abgesehen.
Da reagierte ich.
- Und was wurde aus ihm?
Nemo poimat.
Wahrscheinlich ist er tot, warum?
Nur so.
Ich überlege.
Ich weiss nicht, ich ...
Ich könnte das nie, jemanden ...
Du weisst schon.
Du überlegst zu viel.
Scheisse, was macht der?
(Beat Rhyner)
Ein verdeckter Ermittler
muss sich genau an Auflagen
und Weisungen halten.
Er hat nur
einen begrenzten Spielraum.
Er muss das machen,
was im Plan vorgesehen ist
und was ihm
seine Führungsperson sagt,
damit es
nicht ausser Kontrolle gerät,
damit seine Sicherheit
gewährleistet ist,
damit unser Schutzkonzept
funktioniert.
Siehst du, mein Sohn liebt mich.
Ich bin ein guter Vater.
Ich dachte, du hast keine Kinder.
Ähm ... Ja, meine ... meine Eltern
haben mir das immer vorgelesen.
Deine Eltern?
Dieses Kinderbuch
gibt es noch nicht so lange.
Ach ja? Zeig mal!
Stimmt. Ich habe das meiner Nichte
immer vorgelesen.
Wir müssen los.
Die Gegenseite war die ganze Zeit
extrem vorsichtig.
Sie gingen immer davon aus,
dass möglicherweise
die Polizei involviert war.
Stil Verfolgungswahn.
Dass sie abgehört werden,
überwacht werden.
Und Bobes Chef
hat unseren verdeckten Ermittlern
ganz offensichtlich
nie hundertprozentig getraut.
Okay.
So,
der Goldjunge geht jetzt auf Reisen.
Los geht's.
(Beat Rhyner) Normalerweise ist das
der ideale Moment für einen Zugriff:
wenn das Bild da ist
und bevor das Geld weg ist.
Alle sind vor Ort, es macht peng
und die Polizei ist dort
und alle sind in Handschellen
und man hat das Geld und das Bild.
Aber das war hier gar nicht möglich.
Darum war der Plan, dass,
nachdem der verdeckte Ermittler
das Bild physisch anschauen konnte
und es zum Hotelzimmer
transportiert wurde,
in dem der zweite Ermittler
mit dem restlichen Geld wartete,
man auf dem Weg
bei günstiger Gelegenheit
den Zugriff durch
serbische Spezialeinheiten macht.
* Piepsen *
Wir haben einen Platten.
- Willst du mich verarschen?
Ein platter Reifen -
wie das so ist.
Niemand hat damit gerechnet.
Und alle standen da und dachten:
"Was jetzt?"
Bobe wusste nicht, was machen.
Das Bild war schon eingebaut.
Der verdeckte Ermittler stand dort.
Wir standen dort und dachten:
"Was jetzt?"
"Sollen wir einen Zugriff machen
oder ist das inszeniert?"
"Hat er wirklich einen Platten?"
Bobe wusste nicht, ob etwas mit
seinen Geschäftspartnern faul war.
Wir wussten nicht,
ob Bobe etwas gemacht hatte.
Was jetzt?
* Er startet den Motor. *
Einen Platten. Ich glaube es nicht.
Das darf doch nicht wahr sein.
Verdammt!
- Das kann doch nicht sein!
Verdammt noch mal.
Ist das eine Falle?
Scheisse! Die verarschen uns.
Verdammte Scheisse!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Jetzt sind sie angekommen.
* Hupen *
Das mit dem Platten
glaubt kein Mensch.
Wenn er das Bild schneller will,
soll er die Kohle herbringen.
Hey, Dieter, ich bin's.
Wir hatten einen Platten.
Wir sind in einer Garage.
Kein Scheiss.
Ja.
Schick bitte jemanden mit dem Geld.
Ja, jetzt.
Ich schick dir den Standort.
Es gab Unsicherheit.
Plötzlich zwei neue Sachen:
mehr Geld, abweichen vom Plan.
Ein Defekt am Auto.
Da mussten wir in der Schlussphase
wirklich nochmals improvisieren.
Der bleibt noch.
Alles in Ordnung? Du bist blass.
Alles gut.
- Vorhin ...
Ich dachte, das wären die Bullen.
Die Bullen?
Ich dachte,
du hättest mich verpfiffen.
Wie kommst du jetzt darauf?
- So ein Gefühl in meinen Eiern.
Das mit den Eiern überlässt du
schön mir. Mein Business.
* Dramatische Musik *
* Sirene *
* Er schreit. *
* Düstere Musik *
Es herrschte grosse Erleichterung.
Gleichzeitig wusste man,
dass es noch nicht fertig war.
Zuerst mussten wir herausfinden,
ob es wirklich das Bild war,
oder sind wir in die Falle getappt
und sie haben es noch ausgetauscht?
Dann stieg ich
in den nächsten Flieger
und flog nach Belgrad.
Ich wurde am Flughafen abgeholt.
VIP-mässig wurde ich durch das
Stadtzentrum von Belgrad gefahren,
in die Gerichtsmedizin.
Dort lag das Bild nämlich.
Es war schon fast
eine surreale Szenerie:
Garage, Neonlicht, uniformierte
und zivile Polizisten standen herum.
Man nimmt die Abdeckung weg,
öffnet den Deckel
und dann liegt das Bild dort.
Wir hatten das alle
noch nie in echt gesehen.
Jetzt liegt es da,
ganz unspektakulär.
Das ist es jetzt. Das ist es.
Das war schon ein super Gefühl.
Ich wurde hineingeführt und gebeten,
zu sagen,
ob das tatsächlich unser Bild sei.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Und?
100 % Cézanne.
Wir hatten in dem Fall
den idealen Ausgang:
Wir hatten das Bild zurück.
Das ist für den Kunsthistoriker
und Konservator das Wichtigste.
Wir hatten aber auch
die Festnahme der Räuber.
Was gewissermassen dazu führt,
dass es sich vielleicht
eher nicht wiederholen wird.
Die abschreckende Wirkung,
die so etwas hat,
ist nicht zu unterschätzen.
Das ist für den Staatsanwalt
mindestens so wichtig
wie die Rückführung des Bildes.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
dass solche Tätergruppierungen
vielfach auch Mitglieder vor Ort,
d.h., in Zürich haben,
die für Organisation,
für Logistik verantwortlich sind.
Wenn man den Tätergruppen erlaubt,
sich hier niederzulassen,
werden sie das
weidlich auszunutzen wissen
und es wird im Kanton Zürich
deutlich unsicherer.
Das war ein grosser Erfolg
für die serbische Polizei.
Ich glaube, der bisher grösste
Erfolg auf internationaler Ebene.
Auch die eigentliche Verhaftungs-
aktion war sehr gut organisiert.
Es waren filmreife Szenen.
Einer der Täter wurde von einem
speziellen Polizeiauto verfolgt.
Auf internationaler Ebene
war es einer der grössten Erfolge
überhaupt für die serbische Polizei.
Nach vier Jahren intensiver
internationaler polizeilicher Arbeit
sind die beiden letzten
gestohlenen Werke wieder zurück.
Es war uns klar,
dass uns nur eine Chance blieb.
Ein Fehler, ein falscher Schritt
und das Vertrauen der Täter,
ja, die ganze Operation,
würde Gefahr laufen, zu scheitern.
Der alles entscheidende Faktor -
und das ist vielleicht das Fazit
aus der ganzen Ermittlung -
war die verdeckte Ermittlung.
Das ist kein unumstrittenes
Instrument der Strafverfolgung,
aber in dieser Konstellation ...
... war es die einzige
und letzte Möglichkeit,
an die Bilder heranzukommen
und - wenn man die Ziele
des Staatsanwalts anschaut -
auch das Ziel zu erreichen,
an die Gegenseite heranzukommen.
Und wir mussten auch schauen,
dass wir mögliche Spuren verwischen,
damit der verdeckte Ermittler
nach dem Einsatz verschwindet.
Diese Person löst sich in Luft auf,
verschwindet spurlos.
Die gibt es nicht mehr.
Die hat nie existiert.
Papi?
Wie immer.
- Zu spät?
Sein rechter Arm ist zu lang.
- Ist mir noch gar nie aufgefallen.
Wirklich?
Kann ich dich etwas fragen?
War es das wert?
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Frau) ... genau so,
wie das bedeutende Bild von Cézanne,
der Junge
mit dem wunderschönen roten Gilet.
Das ist nicht nur ein Meilenstein
für die international bedeutende
Sammlung von Emil Georg Bührle,
sondern es ist ein Meilenstein
für die gesamte Kunstgeschichte.
Ich empfinde es als grosses Glück,
dass wir dieses Bild
zusammen betrachten können
und der Diebstahl
keine offene Wunde mehr ist.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023